[Music]
all right a major win for religious
liberty today at the u.s supreme court
as the high court ruled in favor of a
former high school football coach named
joe kennedy who was placed on leave by a
washington school district back in 2015
reciting a prayer at the 50-yard line
after games in a 6-3 decision the court
ruled that kennedy's prayer was
protected speech under the free speech
and free exercise clauses of the first
amendment now writing for the majority
justice gorsuch he wrote that quote that
the first amendment doubly protects
religious speech it's no accident it is
a natural outgrowth of the framers
distrust of government and attempts to
regulate religion and suppress dissent
here with reaction is joe kennedy
himself along with the president and ceo
of the first liberty institute kelly
shackleford is with us uh joe first of
all coach congratulations to you um how
do you feel about
uh i i'm still trying to get accustomed
to oh my gosh we actually won and i
the big sigh of relief and just immense
thankfulness for the courts the lawyers
and every supporter and every american
who made this happen
let's talk about so
you would pray
as i understand after the game at the
50-yard line you did it by yourself
right and then at times people saw what
you were doing and they decided to join
you you didn't force them to join you
you weren't forcing players to join you
you were enforcing
the crowd to join you they would do it
voluntarily on their own correct
that is correct
all right so that's a free exercise of
your faith
you know one of the things that i love
about the nfl
is i think it's spontaneous i'm i
i believe it is uh at the end of a lot
of nfl games you see players from both
teams they get together sometimes the
refs even join in
and they get in a circle they bend the
knee they say a prayer together
um and they walk off the field and
you know if you don't want to watch it
you don't have to watch that part but
you don't have to participate if you
don't want to participate in it um i
think it's a little different than the
kaepernick scandal uh
what do you think joe
i think every american should have the
the same freedoms of everybody else the
first amendment is very clear and i just
i think it's awesome that um for that
this was a big win and it
totally protects all americans so
i i don't expect to be any rioting
whatsoever on this i think everybody
should be partying right now and just
saying hey the first amendment is live
and well for all americans people of
faith different face or no faith at all
uh kelly shackleford will joe get his uh
job back will he get back pay will he
get damages
well sean one of the neat things that
people don't realize is coach didn't ask
for any money uh he wanted to make that
clear
all he wanted
was his job as the football coach
and to be able to say that 15 to 20
second prayer silent prayer after the
game
the court reiterated that that's all he
asked for today
and so
that's what he's going to get unless
they want to defy the supreme court so
this was a
a great win not only for coach he's been
fighting this for six years but for the
president i mean my whole career 33
years fighting for religious freedom
the the default position when there's
religious expression has always been
censorship
well that's over as of today because
we've got a supreme court that makes
the free exercise of religion and free
speech are fully protected joe i can
understand all right you don't want
damages from the school district
definitely take your back pay they owe
you that and make them pay for your
lawyer too
[Laughter]
yeah i'll let the lawyers work that one
out i just i just want to be able to
have the same freedom that i fought for
for 20 years in the marine corps and
it's just great that i have been able to
still continue the fight and defend the
constitution now will you officially be
hired back by the district uh maybe mr
shackleford ask you will he be hired
back that's
that's what that's all he asked for in
the case is to get his job back and to
be able to say that 15 20 second prayer
after the game
the supreme court ruled in his favor and
so unless they wanted to fight the
supreme court that's what should be
coming next and in the fall he'll be
back on the field and he'll be saying a
prayer after the game
are you sure they're not going to try
and keep them off the field why do i i
never trust
school districts at all but you sure
he's going to be back out there
let's hope they don't have that fight
but we're ready to have that fight if
they wanted to find the supreme court i
think they're going to realize they made
a serious mistake i don't expect them to
do that but
we'll be ready if they do well if they
do that at that point then bring me into
the case i'll be a free advisor
and then we'll demand the back pay then
we'll demand damages and i think they'll
probably give in and capitulate and uh
they'll they'll change their mind pretty
quickly at that point uh fear of that
loss is probably greater than the
supreme court loss uh coach great great
case fascinating uh i i applaud you for
standing for your convictions your
belief in god and not backing down good
for you and great job counselor you did
an awesome job hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else